i've got marriage certificates i've got
divorce proceedings from
court and i've got lots of letters
to his ex-wife his new wife and to his
children
hello i'm toby and thank you for joining
me for another video about the personal
life of albert einstein
so let's have a look at these einstein
married his first
wife maleva in january 1903
after they had been together for around
five years
the relationship was in its prime and so
was the academic productivity
it was in 1905 that einstein would
publish his
four major papers that would change the
face of physics
by 1912 however einstein had
started having an affair with his cousin
elsa
malevo knew about this and it put a huge
strain on their relationship
by 1914 this is a letter written from
einstein to malava
detailing some conditions of them
continuing to live together einstein was
demanding that these conditions were to
be met
otherwise they would have to get
divorced and it seems like they were
even
trying to stay together at all just for
the sake of the children
einstein says that you make sure
one that my clothes and laundry are kept
in good order and repair
two that i receive my three meals
regularly
in my room and three that my bedroom and
office are always kept
neat in particular that the desk is
available to me
alone you renounce all personal
relations with me
as far as maintaining them is not
absolutely required
for social reasons you are neither to
expect intimacy from me
nor to reproach me in any way you must
desist
immediately from addressing me if i
request it
and you must leave my bedroom or office
immediately
without protest if i so request
finally you commit yourself not to
disparage me either in word or indeed
in front of my children he ends with a
bit of a final sting
which is to say read this slowly it will
do you
good read it also to your family
they have nothing else to do at this
point clearly they are not on
great terms and are just trying to
live together practically now malevo did
actually accept these conditions
but maybe not surprisingly things didn't
last very long
in this next letter to einstein's cousin
elsa
he says the last battle has been fought
yesterday my wife left for good with the
children
i was at the railway station and gave
them a last
kiss i cried yesterday old like a little
boy yesterday afternoon
and yesterday evening after they had
gone
he says that maleva perceives his
conduct
as a crime against her and the children
you dear little elsie will now become my
wife
and become convinced that it is not at
all so hard to live by my side
he also warns elsa to not go out
alone so that she does not become the
subject of idol gossip
you will have to perform wonders of tact
and restraint
so that you are not looked upon as a
kind of murderess
now this is in 1914 and einstein and
malevo
have now separated and are living apart
but they are still married we saw in
that last letter that
einstein was very upset to see his
children
moving away from him and he feared that
their opinion of him would be
tainted here is a letter from 1915
addressed to his oldest son hans albert
he's excited for them to go on a trip
together
perhaps hiking to italy i'll also
tell you many fine and interesting
things about science and
much else i am very glad that you are
enjoying geometry
it was my favorite pastime when i was
already a bit older than you
around 12 years old but i had no one to
demonstrate anything to me
i had to learn it from books i would
immensely enjoy
being able to teach it to you now but
that's not possible
if you write me each time what you
already know
i'll give you a nice little problem to
solve i found that to be quite a nice
letter from einstein to his son
it's an insight that showed he cared
about his development
and he wanted to make sure that his
children
still looked up to their dad in a
positive way
einstein's youngest son eduard was
diagnosed with schizophrenia at the age
of 20
and spent much of his life
institutionalized
having a very poor relationship with his
father so things weren't always so
positive
fast forward another year to 1916
and we have einstein saying to malava
that he proposes to turn
their tested separation into a divorce
einstein was certainly concerned that
the fact he was still technically
married to malevo
was impacting the public perception
of elsa and causing her stress
people were looking upon her unfavorably
and that's one of einstein's motivations
to rush this divorce along
however thought of a divorce was really
tough on malava
she was the one who was resisting it and
it caused her a great deal of pain and
stress
perhaps related or perhaps not but
soon after this letter malava fell into
very ill health
she was suffering from a heart condition
and
chronic fevers in this letter to
einstein's good friend michelle besso
from september that year he thanks
michelle for the report on malava's
condition
and says from now on i'll not trouble
her anymore with the divorce
so for a couple of years malevos health
put a pause on the divorce proceedings
but she did eventually start to get
better and in this letter to her
written in 1918 einstein says that
the endeavour finally to put my private
affairs in some state of order
prompts me to suggest the divorce to you
for the second time
he's becoming a little bit desperate for
this to be finalized
and goes ahead to propose some support
for malava
in the event of their divorce he offers
9 000
german marks which i believe would be
around
25 000 american dollars today
some of that will be deposited annually
for the benefit of the children
he also offers her his nobel prize or
that would be the monetary prize that
comes along with it
now this is quite interesting because
this letter was written in
1918 and that is a full three years
before einstein was even awarded the
nobel prize
naturally i would make such huge
sacrifices
only in the case of a voluntary divorce
if you do not consent to the divorce
from now on not a cent above 6 000 marks
will be
sent he is urging her to file the
divorce
claim against him so that she remains
the
innocent party eventually the divorce
does go ahead
here i have the document from december
1918
which is the court records of the
divorce proceedings
we have here that einstein was cautioned
to speak the truth
he claims it is correct that i committed
adultery
i have been living together with my
cousin the widow
elsa einstein that is her maiden name
for about four and a half years and have
been continuing these intimate relations
since then my wife has known since the
summer of 1914
that these relations exist between me
and my cousin
and she has made her displeasure known
to me
so there we have in this transcribed and
translated
copy of the original document einstein
admitting what he's done and
acknowledging the reason
for their divorce now it's certainly
true that
all these personal documents from
einstein's life
would never be scrutinized like this or
uploaded to the princeton
archives for historians to look at if it
weren't for the fact that einstein has
been
so idolized to the point where he's kind
of been
elevated to the level of some kind of
saint
people are really interested in the
messy lives
of famous people and it is his great
success
in physics that has meant that things as
random as his divorce proceedings
are out there for the public to read and
look at
perhaps looking at these documents will
encourage you
to idolize ideas more than you idolize
individual people one final note at the
end of this document was that it is
marked
urgent maybe that's because einstein was
ready to
get moving on with his second marriage
and i have that second marriage
certificate
right here june 1919
the marriage between albert einstein and
his cousin
elsa now these two did go on to stay
married until elsa's death
in 1936 and they didn't have
any children together i've certainly
found it quite insightful to read
through a lot of these letters and if
you'd like to do so yourself
all of the links to the originals will
be down in the description
a big thank you to the viewers who
support me on patreon
it is your support that makes these
videos possible
and a special shout out to today's
patreon cat of the day
onyx thanks for watching and i'll see
you next time